Noora is in Annapolis Maryland where 38
year old Jared Ramos is charged with
first-degree murder after yesterday's
mass shooting at the Capitol Gazette
newspaper office police say he killed
five people there at least three others
were hurt four journalists and a sales
assistant for the newspaper were killed
they range in age from 34 to 65 years
old their colleagues offered harrowing
accounts of the attack in their newsroom
one photographer said quote I kept
thinking I can't believe I'm going to
die but the remaining staff members
managed to publish this morning's paper
as usual Norah O'Donnell is outside the
Capitol gives that offices in Annapolis
Nora
good morning hey good morning to you the
police chief tells CBS News this morning
that they do believe that the gunman
acted alone he also said that they have
physically done everything they can with
this crime scene behind us but they
still have a lot of questions the
suspect has been held in the Anne
Arundel County Jail all night long but
he is not cooperating with investigators
the shooting began around 3:00 p.m.
police responded to the scene within 60
seconds they were quick they evacuated
about a hundred and seventy people from
the building and took the alleged gunman
Jared Ramos into custody without an
exchange of gunfire the Anne Arundel
County police chief told us that Ramos
bought this pump-action shotgun that he
used in the attack within the last 18
months now Ramos has a history with the
Capitol Gazette he sued the newspaper
for defamation in 2012 why well the
paper had actually published a story
about Ramos pleading guilty to harassing
a woman he went to high school with the
case was later dismissed with the judge
saying that Ramos does not appear to
have learned his lesson so he got her
big rebuke from the judge as well
there's a Twitter page believed to
belong to Ramos that includes dozens of
angry tweets about this case and the
paper
chip Reid spoke with Brennan McCarthy he
is the lawyer who represented the woman
most harassed in an interview will see
only on CBS this morning you know how to
walk that line where it wasn't a direct
threat it was in direct referential
threat so when there was a reference it
was on another thing like I said he's
smart
so so knew he was dangerous yes Plante
knew he was dangerous but not a judge
couldn't say he's so dangerous I'm
putting him in jail it didn't fit within
the definition it did not fit within the
definition of a direct threat therefore
you can keep getting away with it this
is why I said it was inevitable
something tragic was going to follow
this man and it did in response to the
attack President Trump tweeted yesterday
my thoughts and prayers are with the
victims and their families